elle était pressenti cette étoile chez
le jeune anthony beau père 33 ans du
restaurant à ça il a travaillé pendant
une dizaine d'années chez les plus
grands chefs
installé à blois en bordure de loire il
cuisine bio et local autre nouvelle
étoile au firmament du loir et cher la
maison d'à côté à mon niveau
chez emmanuel et christophe et
christophe 37 ans est diplômé du lycée
hôtelier de blois où il a rencontré eric
réclère futur chef du rendez vous des
pêcheurs à blois
son dada cuisiner des produits du
terroir dont les poissons de loire enfin
le dernier entré au michelin est une
bonne table du giennois côté jardin tenu
par sophie et arnaud guillard en tout
trois nouvelles entrées au michelin qui
voit ses ventes baisser mais conserve un
certain prestige